et donc de pourrait bien être l'année
grâce à des gestes brusques fait ce
qu'ils disent les enfants
je sais que c'est toi tu
je sais que c'était toi t'as rien contre
moi pas vrai
je la regardais le monde amérique et toi
c'est ton père est une légende
vous êtes disparaît
tu sais pas tenir tête à ton père moi
ces plans foireux j'en peux plus je le
suis de me dire que je vais t'écraser
ton sale [ __ ] crâne de m
j'essaye juste d'être là pour ma famille
cole on va le coincer crie on va le coin
c'est au tchad
ils vont pas tarder à lui tomber dessus
tout les côtés
étant pas fait de l'orbieu tenant à la
police ou les services secrets ils
veulent nous rayer de la carte
ils ont pas encore gagné
takkal restait qu'une vie
[Musique]
tu veux apaiser
je t'aime tellement malin
voyager pour mieux régner
[Musique]